c'est la plus grande catastrophe
ferroviaire que paris ait connu le
dernier bilan qui nous est parvenu vers
12h30 fait état donc de 50 morts
l'accident est survenu à une heure de
grand trafic entre paris et la banlieue
c'est à dire autour de 19h hier soir on
évalue à environ 1000 personnes
le nombre de passagers à bord des deux
trains celui qui était à quai en gare de
lyon et l'autre dont les freins n'ont
pas fonctionné et qui s'est encastrée
dans le premier nous allons revenir bien
sûr sur les circonstances de l'accident
nous irons ensuite en direct à la gare
de lyon rejoint de pascal deschamps pour
voir où on en est des opérations de
sauvetage mais tout de suite le drame
qu'ont vécu tous ces passages
aucun mouvement est assez fort pour
décrire cette catastrophe des visions
d'horreur aussitôt après le choc
les secours sont pourtant arrivés très
vite il faut leur rendre hommage le samu
et les sapeurs pompiers la croix rouge
l'assistance publique et toute la nuit
une reporter ont suivi leur tentative
désespérée pour sauver les passagers
reportage agnès poirier et
deux trains de banlieue au chevet très
mal gré la fouille des secouristes de
150 pompiers
les scies à métaux résonne sous les
plafonds du québe du troisième sous sol
de la gare de lyon luttent et lutter
contre les secondes précieuses qui
s'écoule combattre la tôle l'amas de
ferraille qui emprisonne les passagers
l'opération porte officiellement ce nom
terrible d incarcération
vision d'horreur pour les pompiers ces
corps déchiquetés sous le choc
ces corps que l'on extrait avec
précaution même s'ils sont unanimes et
toute la nuit le commandant viger nous
informe de l'ampleur de la catastrophe
le nombre de morts s'accumulent d'heure
en heure grave on était les victimes
gisent sous des bâches en plastique
à l'extérieur de la gare le pc du samu
15 ambulance de réanimation
une vingtaine l'équipe de médecins
anesthésistes l'accès aux zones de soins
est interdite aux curieux dans le hall
les familles angoissées attendent
silence peur panique
le commandant vigie rassure tente
d'expliquer aux uns et aux autres que
tout le monde fait le maximum et vers
une heure du matin c'est le soulagement
pour certains les listes des blessés
évacués sont enfin affiché lui le drame
se poursuit sur le quai b au troisième
sous-sol à 3 heures du matin le bilan
est de 16 morts et puis il ya cette
lueur d'espoir trois personnes vivantes
ont été repérés par les pompiers
découper des tôles
de nous approcher des ailes un médecin
est auprès d'elle à perfuser cette
personne est en train de les soigner
pendant ce temps des coupes autour et
petit à petit on attendait les dégager
rapidement un bloc opératoire est
improvisé sur le quai constat tragique
des médecins il va falloir amputé des
deux jambes l'une de ces trois personnes
coincées sous la ferraille miraculeux
cette jeune fille est enfin libéré
transporté dans une couverture de survie
sa vie est encore en danger elle a passé
12 heures comprimé entre deux wagons
longue très longue nuit pour tous les
secouristes épuisé
au lever du jour il n'y a plus d'espoir
de retrouver des survivants
à présent il faudra à l'aide d'engins
des encastré la motrice sous laquelle il
ya toujours de nombreux corps
[Musique]